so I work on the Python tools team at
Microsoft let's see what else can I
mention I guess I'm still considered a
junior developer at least the youngest
one on my team so we're gonna talk a bit
about Python and Azure
so the world is full of cloud providers
at this point plenty of you are probably
using things that aren't Azure and it's
okay to admit it just not too loudly on
campus here you can go across the
highway I'm sure anybody else will be
happy to hear about it so with the rest
of the market though you'd think that in
order to get any customers address going
to have to do something to differentiate
themselves now a lot of people like to
brag about how they can deploy your
cloud service into the internet and be
in the cloud and you can run your stuff
and we can run pass workloads platform
as a service or infrastructure as a
service but there's nothing really
impressive about this we say this all
the time like it's a big deal and we've
been doing this for years everyone can
do that without any issues and if we
stand to deliver anything of value to
customers we need to start talking about
the things we can do beyond just getting
you a VM running a web service now this
isn't to somehow bring down what it is
Asscher has done so we are we're
currently deployed in 19 regions we have
over 1.2 million sequel databases
deployed and the current input to our
networking balancers is about 3 million
requests a second and these aren't
exactly small numbers but we're still
not talking about the right things all
of those things talk about the very
normal things you were doing is assisted
min before you had your machine your
sequel database and a website we're not
really delivering anything you couldn't
have done yourself before now I think
this is personally really sad because we
have services that do these things that
do things that are beyond what you are
currently doing that we can provide you
to make your life truly better and for
providing this experience you can
actually deliver something your
customers that they haven't seen before
so today we're going to utilize a sample
app I wrote that brings 14th century
technology into the 21st I've made a
website that allows you to purchase
groceries on the Internet
what this uses is Django it uses it in
Python 3 and it's just a simple
ecommerce site you can buy your items
you can browse you can log in store your
address pretty much all the things
you've expected from an e-commerce site
but I don't want it to show you any
e-commerce site like I said this talk is
about how can a sure differentiate
itself so the few things we're going to
look at we're going to look at how we
can validate customer addresses in a
quick and easy way that doesn't take
much time we're going to talk about how
you can use our services to recommend
customers purchases and suggest the
things that they might have wanted that
they didn't even know yet and maybe just
keep them on the site a little longer
make some impulse purchases and generate
some revenue we'll also talk if these
things aren't enough about how you might
write these services yourself so not
just recommendations and addresses but
pretty much any machine learning
workload you can think of we'll also
talk a bit about telemetry because most
websites without telemetry are just sort
of blind we don't know what our
customers are using we don't know when
things are breaking and that data is
crucial to running successful web
service we host the thing called the
azure marketplace
these are api's you can purchase and
datasets as well that you can use with
your applications most all of these
things are REST API is that are pretty
easy to digest and using something like
requests can easily be on-boarded to
your workload the first one we'll look
at is an address validation service it's
provided by a company called melissa
data and it serves u.s. and canadian
addresses address checks for whatever
reason are a very popular thing there
are about a dozen of these I just picked
this one I'm by no way saying it's the
best one it's just one that I found that
worked well also we're going to go onto
that my mistake so we have an address
page this is a simple profile it's a
little less complicated than it might be
in the real world but you'll notice on
screen there's a mistake Microsoft isn't
Crites pelled correctly without validate
we'd attempt to send this to the
customer and they wouldn't get their
items now we hope it's not something as
bad as the city name or the zip code for
instance an interesting fact is the zip
code for Olympia Washington is the
second or the last two digits transposed
so nine eight to five is Olympia and if
you enter that wrong into a website with
a common address say first Street 140th
the street your items are going to go to
someone entirely different than you and
that's going to be tragic you're gonna
pay for goods and something like
groceries they spoil so it's not like we
can send it to you later we've now lost
those Goods so what if instead of just
having it wrong we could correct it for
you and display you an error that told
you you've done something wrong correct
it and have you resubmit with the
corrected address information what's on
screen now is Python tools for Visual
Studio this is one of the products I
work on a Microsoft it's an IDE that's
usable on Windows from inside Visual
Studio that provides you with a nice
editor intellisense debugging support as
well as deployment help to things like
Azure the highlighted lines in the
middle are really the interesting things
it takes to do address checking all we
really need to do is put our address in
a format that's understandable by the
web service call that URI using requests
with the address a maximum suggestion
and a confidence interval something that
will stop it from giving us more or less
meaningless results and we can now know
whether or not your address matches
what's in the postal database and now
instead of shipping your stuff to the
wrong place you're going to get your
groceries so that one's pretty easy
though it doesn't really require a lot
of machine learning
all right the database is something
that's well understood all they're
really doing is probably something like
Hamming distance between the what you
entered and what exists in the database
so let's look at recommendations
recommendations is a service provided by
Microsoft it's written by a team we have
here and it allows you to do machine
learning train your model and then
request against that live service for
recommendations based on the items in
your store
so how might that look this is an item
page on Azure fresh it's pretty basic it
has a price the description picture we
could add a recommendations area
something that gave you items you may
have wanted to purchase in this case we
think carrots and peas go well together
so we recommend that to you
this is binding the simplest form of a
dress recommend a turd pet a dress
recommendations for your service here so
I'm using what's called a frequently
bought together algorithm it simply
pulls in the frequency of purchases it's
just an expectation really you can go as
far to look at the individual customer
the things they purchase in the past the
things in their cart and use that to
determine this area - I chose to keep it
simple as that's a really big thing and
deserves a talk of its own but it's a
very flexible API that's capable of way
more than I'm using it for so we have to
train our data and that's what's on
screen now it's a little more
complicated than the address thing
because in the dresses we didn't have to
Train anything but the training is
pretty simple we use a library called
recommendations service it's fairly
simple library all it does is wrap
request calls and so we provided an
email and key so we can authenticate
with Azure data marketplace we create a
model by any name in this case groceries
with a date time after it we import a
catalog of items that is to say
everything in our store we import a
transactional history of purchases so we
can correlate the items in our store and
how they might be purchased together
once we've imported those we can build
our model and we set the current model
to the one we just built and that's it
this takes between five and ten minutes
to run in my store I have around fifty
items it's obviously going to take a
little longer the more you have but you
only do this occasionally in my case I
ran this once and I because I haven't
changed my items so whenever you get new
purchases you might want to rerun this
now again like addresses though calling
the web service it's relatively simple
we authenticate again to the
recommendation service we request a
recommendation based on the model ID we
ran before
and the string ID that represents the
product and the last line we have a bit
of fun using the Django ORM system to
take the idea that we received and map
it to an actual product item and that's
how we end up with a JPEG of the the
item itself the price and so forth so
all the training really needs is a
number that correlates and that's it we
now have recommendations in a website as
I said the marketplace is quite vast
there are many solutions to solve even a
single problem like address validation
and I encourage you check it out on
screen you can see we offer some I told
you Melissa data does then third parties
are allowed and you can publish services
here too so if you make service and say
our ml you can publish it here and you
can charge for it so this is an avenue
for you even to generate revenue if
you'd like but let's say you go through
everything in the data marketplace but
there's something you still need for
your workload for you we have the Azure
machine learning studio here you can
make your own machine learning projects
publish them as web services and consume
them through REST API so the nice thing
about the azure ml studio is it doesn't
require that you have a PhD in data
science to do data science things I
spent the majority of my career doing
things that in no way related to data
science and I can use this
I've spent probably only two to three
weeks total in the studio and so far
I've been able to sort of impress myself
with the things I've been able to
accomplish despite the fact I still have
no idea what a decision jungle actually
is so you can also go ahead and use this
for things that aren't data science
which is something that sort of was
profound to me we call this thing the ML
Studio so on screen you can see an
execute Python block this can take any
code do you want an output any code you
want so you could go as far to use this
for any web service and use it to
publish so you don't need to have your
own place to host rest api's you can use
us will host the endpoint will handle
the API keys we'll deal with the hard
part's setting up the intro entry and
the exit and you can just worry about
the middle the algorithm that you
understand as a computer scientist or a
data
scientist so this here is showing just
how easy it is to get a web service
going to get to this point all I did is
take what you saw in the previous screen
and click a set up web service button
it's a text where the inputs and outputs
are and then you can configure in the
properties which ones you want to expose
and then after this we simply say
publish you'll be given an API key as
well as a web and point that you can use
it will take in JSON information and
spit it out it back out at you with your
output and so now we can host those
api's for you and if you're using this
for more complicated things let's say
you have a bunch of intermediate steps
and you want to look at what was going
on at the end of this step this middle
area not just the end you can use our
notebook experience on any one of those
nodes you can right click you'll be
displayed in notebook and you can choose
to open it in Python 2 or python 3 and
what it will do is it'll launch you a
jupiter notebook that you can use to
play with your data this screenshot here
is something we did during the keynote
this morning
it's simply consuming a service that I
have published using the marketplace or
the ML Studio my mistake the nice thing
about this is it utilizes the library
we've created called Asher ml and so
rather than going through all the work
of authoring request calls and trying to
form the data yourself we can help you
along and so we've provided some
decorators here that all you have to
describe to us is what types you have
for input and what you expect the output
to be named and we can provide you with
the inner code of that function you
don't need to worry about whether or not
you understand web calls or not so I've
talked about how you can make some
services how you can use some services
what about knowing if these are being
used and knowing how they're changing
the way a customer interacts with your
site this is where application insights
comes in I find that collecting decent
telemetry data is one of the most
important things about running a
successful cloud service so it's all
fine and good to create the best site in
the world but ultimately what good is
that if you don't know if it's being
used application insights is a way to
get this information simply so this
dashboard here required about it's under
ten lines of code from me and signing up
and when you sign up without your
websites they even create one of these
for you the way this works behind the
scenes is it gives us a web service
provided by application insights and
they give a grid and you take this grid
and you make web service calls to them
with your telemetry data and then it's
up in this dashboard so I told you
pretty simple code in Django we can use
whiskey middleware and these two lines
are going to give us all server side
requests and failures the dashboard I
showed you earlier has the ability to
have alerting and so with these two
lines of code and a few clicks on the
portal you'll now have an understanding
of how many customers are using your
site when they're using your site how
you need to be scaling if things are
failing why you'll get a stack trace you
can go back and try to fix your problem
two lines of code and if we want it to
go a little further than that they
provide in the portal these few lines of
JavaScript code so again I want to
stress you don't have to write this it's
it's kind of ugly it's not formatted
well but this here will give you
client-side reporting the handy thing
about this is it will go as far to let
you know how long it took a client to
load your page where were they when they
tried to load your page what browser
were they in and so you can start to
understand if there's an issue with
Chrome all of a sudden for instance so
to dive in a bit deeper deeper here's
the page views page now I think this one
is particularly interesting to me and
it's pretty easy to get to for the
grocery site we can see in the lower
left-hand corner of the screen a list of
the different items people have been
looking at so something about our store
makes people be on the home page about
twice as often as absolutely anywhere
else and they seem to like apples more
data like this might make you go I
should sell more apples people like them
and hopefully more interesting
information
my store is kind of silly it has you
know fruits and vegetables it doesn't
really go very deep but you can see how
things like this could allow you to draw
deeper correlations in you're far more
complicated marketplace so let's say
again kind of similar to the pattern
before after all of this you're not
getting what you need you need deeper
data you have maybe a long workflow that
has sub steps you're caring about
application insights is flexible enough
to allow you to record any event trace
metric or exception you want and all you
need to do is use their telemetry client
I didn't mention earlier application
insights is a pipey package very simply
install and works on virtually any
platform for those of you that don't do
everything in Python this works over
JavaScript nodejs Ruby dotnet and more
and so since they've written platforms
everywhere for those of you with mixed
workloads where maybe you have a native
application running on a Mac maybe you
have a Windows application you have your
web service you can use this logging in
all of those places similar to before
custom events have their ability to be -
boarded what you see here is some
diagnostic searching as well as filtered
events and how you might see this data
it's not too different from before the
only thing worth calling out is that
this is it is extendable enough that you
can continue to add any event you need
for your task we've worried about the
basic ones but we accept that you might
want more than page views so as I tried
to show asher has an advanced ecosystem
full of lots of things that we can use
it has the ability to write machine
learning algorithms consume other
people's record what your data does and
publish into the cloud and all of these
things go above and beyond just getting
a website up and running which is what
it seems we want to tell you about and
these things we just keep like their
little secrets that we don't want to
share with the world so with the help of
Microsoft Azure after amount of bit of
app insights we have created a better
user experience for our customers
so what I have here too is for anyone
that wants a Jew fresh is actually a
sample on my github page there are
complete instructions on how to do
everything I showed today and you can
you can go from a basic a basic repo
without of these changes make them
yourself publish to Azure and sort of
see how these things work and hopefully
over time that will continue to grow so
you might want to watch it and watch for
updates because I kind of keep adding
new things that are in Azure that I
think are interesting so if that's it I
was hoping to answer any questions
people might have and I'm happy to dive
into anything I didn't mention about
Azure that you'd like to talk about
Bueller
so I'm going to answer that with an O
and IC dino has a really big grin so I
want him to answer now
so part of that part of the fun and I
talked to someone earlier Dino's the I
would I would put at this point the
brainchild behind the notebook service
the big issue is PI P is unvetted and so
anything that's allowed to be installed
from pip hasn't really been checked to
be okay
and so it's we all see it as a safe
place but it's far from and when we're
putting you in a shared system with
other users that is even more important
than when you're just on your own
machine
you should be yeah yeah
yeah so I'm gonna I'm just gonna back
off of the slide ice and everyone's had
a chance to see it and I'll set set
myself back to non duplicating so I can
drive you through some stuff
so Azure Azure ml is published as a pipe
II package that we can use and so if I
go here quick back to so this here is
calling into a dremel well this allows
you to do is everything from playing
with your data which is what I do in
this sample and just simply looking at
the frame and we can do you know some
more interesting things we could plot
for instance age against work class or
bachelor's degrees let's say look at
education and so this allows you to play
with that that's the simple version
right we're just looking at datasets the
two other things it does that are big
that's not to say it's everything it
does you can publish add your ml
services using this so you can do your
stuff in Python and publish it all
through the SDK you can also consume
them and so if I go here so I showed
some of this this morning during the
keynote but it was a bit bit quick so I
didn't describe everything that's going
on this time we import services and we
can call here team one wins is actually
going to make a request call to our
service through here you can do this on
your own it's it's not actually terribly
difficult but it is kind of messy and
there's a good chance you won't get it
quite right the nice thing about this is
it's it kind of leads you down the right
path if you use requests I'm a really
big fan of the request library and
whenever it comes to doing pretty much
any sort of getter post you can use URL
Lib too and stuff if you want as well
but really that's all you need to do to
consume something they're all rest
endpoints and so for the most part they
take some JSON data package packed up
send it over there's a post request and
it comes back at the response the
publishing is the interesting part and
that's something I don't show and I'm
assuming that Deana will show that in
his talk on operationalization yes
tomorrow at 11:40 so he'll go into much
more detail on that
okay well it looks like we're gonna be
done a little early it's not a bad thing
seeing is the way the days went it might
might be okay
so